okay
das video das los geht eine ganz kurze
sache und zwar eigentlich angekündigt
dass ich zu jedem tag während des
urlaubs hier einen blog auf einem kanal
raushauen werde leider leben nicht nur
wie auf dieser insel sondern auch sehr
viele andere und sehr sehr viele
zuschauer von mir
[Musik]
auf jeden fall
und zwar auf jeden fall einige fans
verfolgt und wirklich nicht nur einfach
und auf der straße gestanden was auch
schon zu weit geht sondern auch
teilweise irgendwie zum haus noch mit
hin und irgendwie direkt fast mit
reingekommen und so das war nicht so
cool und das lag leider daran dass ich
ein bisschen viel gezeigt haben von
unter anderem morus haus hier
dafür auf jeden fall der grund warum ich
mir gedacht habe okay ich hatte keine
blogs geladen wird jetzt einfach ein
bisschen schön bisschen urlaub machen
aber dann habe ich diesen wundervollen
lektüren in meinem schlafzimmer gefunden
in der jugendherberge wir haben hier
nämlich einmal es klopft bei wanja in
der nacht und wir haben das buch auge
kopf pferde bekommen
und daraus werden wir euch heute
vorlesen also willkommen zu lukas
lesestunde
sage ich drücke selber das buch in die
hand angefangen mit der ersten zeile des
buchs weit fort in einem kalten land
steht man das haus
erhängt und drinks
und das waren wir heute morgen machen so
hörte dass hier sind wir ist bei sturm
in finsterer in die provinz trafik
wir besitzen das team kollege von uns
ist er heute morgen war schon abgefahren
jetzt und irgendwie verfolgt er uns aber
trotzdem besser sein geist ist immer
noch da ist bei sturm in finsternis
also ich nicht einmal von vorne der ist
bei sturm im film
der mann ja plötzlich aufgabe der
das ist typisch natürlich geht jetzt
hier ab das höre ich da trocken so fragt
er sich erschrocken wer ist der kopf oft
daran sein dass
sie aus führt
ein hase kocht im schneesturm daraus der
schreib- und was hat wirklich die
verschiedene so magath
wir waren ja sagt kommission reinigte
sie gleich im ofen hat
es war die wärme dringt bis in die haut
moment moment moment was hat waren ja
vor mit dem hasen waren wir als wir
machen jetzt eine kurze exklusion zu
werden trotz seiner kleinen körpergröße
das shetlandpony ein kräftiges und
redest ihres ponys übersteht das trauer
und klage klima der shetland islands
land
das gutmütige kleine fertig kann auch
sehr gut von kindern gerieten
[Musik]
auch wanja deck dich wieder zu gut nach
und angenehmen also irgendwie finde das
ganze buch an das war ja nach hause kam
und irgendwie die bude ein gehalt oder
wie jetzt wieder überall besoffene tiere
um unterdessen tobt weiter
lesen dass
dieses mächtige kaltblutpferd ist das
größte aller ferne es kann ein stockmaß
von über 2 meter haben wollen mein
schwanz
[Gelächter]
die
präsidentin existenz
des videos jetzt wirklich noch mal ein
wegen der text hier wurde das pferd wäre
der weg des menschen in die zivilisation
weitaus mühsamer gewesen
man kann sich heute kaum noch vorstellen
dass viele lebensbereiche früher einmal
vom pferd abhängig war
nur ein jahr bis leute die befürchteten
man würde werde in zukunft nur noch im
zu betrachten können doch im gegenteil
waren die pferde früher bei der arbeit
unentbehrlichen sie die menschen heute
als partner in freizeit und sport
turniere und pferderennen 7 tausende von
besuchern an es gibt viele zuchtvereine
die sich um die erhaltung alter oder
besonderer pferderassen bemühen und fast
jedes kind träumt einmal davon ein
eigenes pferd zu besitzen an der stelle
würde ich das heutige video beenden